[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
daily mirrors political editor pippa
carrera and the times home affairs
editor matt dathan they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight very
good to see you so let's see what's on
some of those front pages which are
coming in a little slowly tonight as
perhaps you might imagine given the
drama that took place at about nine
o'clock this evening the guardian
declares that the prime minister is
clinging to power after vote humiliation
is how they term it
the financial times describes mr johnson
as wounded by tonight's result
is what the metro says
the party
is over
boris
and a very interesting headline on the
telegraph calls it a hollow victory
which tears the tory apart
and the sun calls it night of the blonde
knives
while the star is unimpressed with the
prime minister and is allies their
headline
carry on pinocchio
and just to remind you that by scanning
the qr code you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us analyzing and discussing them
all we're joined by pippa carrera and
mark dathan as i say pippa uh kick us
off i mean there's only one big story in
town of course there is let's start with
the guardian now what do they make of it
well unsurprisingly like all the papers
they're going on boris johnson's uh vote
of
confidence which was he won but 41 of
his mps
voted against him which really bodes
very badly for the next few months and
suggests that the prime minister is in
for a very bumpy time indeed the
guardian splash is pm clinging to power
after vote humiliation would you go that
far would you say it is a humiliation i
think it is i mean despite the fact that
we heard that clip from the prime
minister in number 10
just
less than an hour ago in which he
described it as a good result that he
said it was decisive and that has
allowed the party to move on the reality
is is that there are still some moments
of great peril for the prime minister
coming up not least the two by-elections
were expecting onto the 23rd not least
the commons privileges committee inquiry
into whether he misled the house over
partygate and then of course the
prospect of
all of these tory rebels that have
emerged this evening blocking or at
least not being helpful in terms of the
legislation that the government wants to
get through i mean he potentially is a
lame duck prime minister and look matt i
mean look at the face the picture well
this to say tells a thousand words or
whatever um the prime minister's face
stoney faces he's driven away then
absolutely and uh what was interesting
we learned today was that he actually
found out just before the pageant
yesterday uh when we were all enjoying
just a few yards away from here uh the
the jubilee pageant and he had to sit
through hours of that and again here
today um
he doesn't look good at all and i think
he tried to put on a brave face but i
think a lot of his critics are calling
him delusional tonight by saying he's
going to plow on and as pippa said and
as the guardian is saying he's
effectively lost his majority and that's
going to be really crucial when it comes
down to really contentious legislation
and we've got two more years of
the parliament to go unless unless there
is a snap election so it's going to be a
rocky rocky road okay let's let's have a
look at your paper matt uh the times and
we have here pretty much the same
analysis
and i wonder if that's almost the same
picture but even closer up a wounded
victor i mean yeah
but how wounded terminal well i mean he
has to be uh
almost fairly wounded really when his
own allies were going around today
saying that uh anything you know
anything they're aiming for below 100
and i mean even some of the rebels
weren't expecting anything more than 130
really when you when they were really
counting up the numbers it's 148 was it
thirty
thirty three or thirty two shy of losing
uh
power in this building it's um it's
incredible and it's and it's the
percentages people people have been
looking at as well comparing
particularly to theresa may who got 63
percent uh and boris johnson got 59
percent yes that's right and in fact it
wasn't just theresa may who of course
won that uh that no confidence vote but
then was out of office within six months
found it impossible to govern but going
back further margaret thatcher under a
different set of rules at the time also
won a leadership vote a confidence vote
and ended up stepping down shortly
afterwards and john major didn't step
down originally afterwards but was
absolutely thrashed in the 1997 general
election against labour and lost power
that way so what i find really
interesting this evening is that there
are allies of the prime minister saying
that president uh the president that
seems to have been set by those three
previous conservative leaders in similar
situations will not apply to him because
of course the popularity because he's
borrowed his job because he's boris
johnson and apparently the usual the
usual rules don't apply to boris johnson
he defies the laws of political gravity
whether that turns out to be the case
here his allies don't think it is or at
least they don't hope it is we're gonna
have to wait and see but matt what about
the laws of the conservative party and
the 1922 committee which if he's won
this vote technically he can't face a
challenge again for another year but as
people were saying of course that
applied to theresa may but look what
happened to her
i think it's irrelevant really what the
rules are right now i think come the end
of june and uh it seems quite a long way
away now but
in the 23rd of june facing two key
by-elections
we saw a poll yesterday showing
wakefield's they're on course to lose by
about 20 points to labour and tibetan
and hunterton and devon uh 24 000
majority if they were to lose that's the
dems which the odd the bookmakers are
saying they will i think there is
nothing stopping the 22 if 150 tory mps
are coming to them and saying look we
really need another vote i don't think
that i think the rules are irrelevant so
i mean those by-elections if he hangs on
till then say wakefield's gone what
happens if they hold the other one could
that shore him up it could a bit i mean
the reality is that these are both
symbolic and different ways wakefield of
course was a seat which was won by the
tourists for the first time in many
decades of the 2019 general election in
the so-called red wall of seats across
the midlands of the north that fell um
they fell for all the labour lost and
the tories won at that election and
boris johnson was credited with that and
the result in wakefield is certain to
really put the jitters um on a lot of
red wall tory mps a majority of whom
some foreign allies believe tonight
actually voted against him in that
contest that we saw earlier today so
you'll have the jitters going on amongst
the red wall mps but then also the
so-called blue wall i mean it's all
colors these days but they're more
traditional conservative seats across
the south and the south east tibetan
honda obviously in devon one of those
seats that could potentially fall to the
lib dems lots of uh longer standing
conservative mps starting to talk about
how they're hearing from their
constituents they don't like the sort of
lack of property that they're seeing in
this building the party gate scandal
exemplifies that
the bay city rollers are rewritten
protesters at the gates of downing
street let's have a look at the
telegraph all important of course for
the the
tory uh supporters and the tory
constituency and this is this is brutal
isn't it matt uh
hollow victory tears tories apart
does that mean they think that it's
going to be a leadership contest and
that really will be presumably hard
fought well i think when the
conservative prime minister is starting
to lose the telegraph especially boris
johnson that's his paper that's where he
worked for years i think that's going to
really hurt him and i think maybe over
the coming days maybe we might see a
change in tone from the prime minister
we don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow let alone next week but what i
found also interesting tonight was the
spectator magazine the tory leading
magazine say
their headlines this evening where um he
might have won the vote but he lost the
party he's lost the party so two really
key conservative uh publications really
not giving him very good headlines yeah
do you go along with that yeah
absolutely and then conservative mps
that started to come out in their dozens
today to publicly denounce the prime
minister and say that they wanted him
gone it's a worry for the prime minister
because those voices get heard i mean
there's some high profile ones there was
jeremy hunt of course who's been sort of
sitting on the bench so far saying that
he didn't think it was the right time
because the ukraine crisis to hold a
leadership contest however made it quite
clear today was one of the first at the
traps in fact to suggest that he was
going to vote against the prime minister
he's tipped as a future liberty
leadership contender they're all going
to be jostling position and i think
matt's right and that the prime minister
if he's going to show up his position
he's going to have to slightly change
the tone and
stop suggesting that anybody that is
concerned about probity and number 10 is
obsessed by is obsessed by and focusing
on the wrong things the issues that
don't matter start realizing that of
course issues that matter to people at
the moment a cost of living crisis
things like housing we're going to see
some speeches from him in the coming
days one with rishi sinai concentrating
on the economy they're going to have to
try and shore up that support persuade
many of their touring piece who don't
currently think that the government is
actually focused there's things that is
drifting and it's lacking direction and
also behind the scenes convince those
tory mps that actually did support him
this time that they need to continue to
do so because the danger of course is it
was another contest and some of those
that didn't that backed in this time
will change their minds well i'm going
to give you uh the daily mirror because
people would obviously say it was great
and let's just have a look at the front
page on pippa's paper
hard to say party's over boris and and
again you know an endless number of
photographs to accompany these stories
yeah photographers must have had a field
day but i'm going to embarrass people by
pointing out people is partly
responsible for for this day really with
paul brown from itv breaking all the
party gate scoops and uh that that's a
headline that's a front page i'm sure
we'll go off
in the wall but um
i i think uh i guess it would be
expected whether the daily mirror would
be going with the headline but i think
going back to the tory headlines at the
papers i think once boris johnson wakes
up tomorrow and it starts to sink in i
think i think there has to be a change
of tone because today we saw so many
threats from the whips going around
saying we're going to be broken
financially in your constituency
um even jacob smog apparently saying
that could be a snap election and boris
johnson pointedly not ruling that out
one of his aides told me tonight that uh
he might be threatening a vote of a
general election a snap election but
there's no way he's going to do that
well he did rule that out actually when
our ali fortescue talked to him but i
mean a snap election paper remember
looking at the polling his own seat is
under threat yes and that's actually a
calculation that many tory mps were
making tonight do they think that that a
tory government under anyone but boris
johnson would stand a better chance of
winning the next election than a tory
government under boris johnson all the
polls suggest if there's an election
tomorrow the tories would lose it but
boris johnson has got this long
tradition of of defying the laws of
political gravity and they hope tonight
that he will be able to bounce back
they'll be able to show up his support
they'll be able to set a direction for
the government and of course as we all
know he's a formidable campaigner and
actually he is still as their best
chance albeit with all those caveats of
leading them to victory at the next
election welcome back you are watching
the press preview right here on sky news
with me now pippa carrera and matt
dathan and we are diving into the papers
all reacting to the drama of today the
vote of confidence in boris johnson
let's have a look at the metro first of
all in this section there we go and uh
of course boris johnson has survived but
a large proportion of his mps voted
against him not enough of course to
dislodge him right now but even so the
papers are discussing possible rivals
the jeremy hunt is on to get it identify
tory challengers right pippa possible
rivals two of them pictured there uh
penny mordent and ben wallace so are
they two of the front runners ben
wallace is always or over the last
couple of months has topped all the
polls of conservative party members who
of course have the final say in the
contest the mps whittle it down to two
candidates and those two candidates then
go on a tour of hustings around the
country
and it's up to the members to decide so
ben wallace and liz trust have kind of
been in the top two on and off for the
last the last few months penny morgan's
seen as sort of the dark horse candidate
it was interesting today when she was
asked whether she supported boris jones
and she refused to say one way or the
other she is of course a serving
minister so you would expect her to back
the prime minister but for a long time
she's been talked about as a potential
fresh face she's a brexiteer she's kind
of regarded as presentable to the
country she might be somebody that could
inject a bit of
you know novelty if you like it
resignation fears about her in number 10
that she might walk and they and with
the rumor the rumor going around
westminster tonight just across the road
is that there will be resignations from
government ministers tomorrow so we've
got that to look out for as well whether
she's amongst them or not i don't know
but yes so you'll see what happens
tomorrow okay matt um riders so we had
two of them there who else would you
pick out they had jeremy hunt in there
sub headline there as well
yeah i mean jeremy hunt seems to be the
front runner with the bookmakers and
interestingly penny morden it was a dark
horse just a few days ago but she's now
second favorite with the bookmakers um
and liz trust is the clear
uh well the clear candidate from the
cabinet i think and richie sunak hasn't
ruled well
he's taking it totally damaged or do you
think i don't think so no and if you
look at the resignations today well not
the resignations the letters a lot of
former treasury ministers who worked
alongside him jesse norman he was he
came out with incredibly stinging
criticism and i don't think he would
have done that without talking to rishi
sooner i mean i don't know that but and
then the pending back to penny mordant
people think that andrew ledson was
possibly the stalking horse last week
and would maybe run her leadership
campaign possibly being the chancellor
she's always wanted to be they really
are jockeying for position then i mean
there could be what potentially dozens
of contenders was you only need eight
mps to be nominated that was the case
last time i mean i think last time there
was ten that ended up going for it first
time and this time i think we probably
see similar numbers what's interesting
about this time though is that boris
johnson was the clear favorite to win
for the beginning and of course won this
time all bets are off really and yes of
course the bookies have their favorites
and the party members have their
favorites and the mps of course have
their favorites but it's an unknown it's
all to play for so i said i imagine
there'll be quite a few people the next
generation perhaps people like tom tugan
throwing their hat in the ring and
thinking now is the moment okay uh we'll
squeeze another paper in let's see what
we've as i say they're just coming in as
we speak it is the sun uh matt knight of
the blonde knives a political reference
there as well to the night of the long
knives please explain yeah absolutely i
mean that's another classic tabloid
headline isn't it harking back to
the 1980s um
we had when boris johnson came in um as
prime minister he axed i think 11
cabinet ministers i think we had very
similar headlines uh then um
when i'm not you know i'm not sure
it takes a few looks at that to try and
work out exactly what they're going for
i think but uh
and let's have a quick look at the uh
star
and uh perhaps echoing what uh the
protesters at the end of downing streets
are saying uh yes uh carry on pinocchio
so pipper i mean you know reference
there to carry on and of course uh boris
johnson's reputation amongst uh some
people including those protesters for
perhaps not being entirely
accurate with the truth the star have
not been been shy in coming forward when
it comes to criticizing the prime
minister throughout they've had a field
day with the party gateway
and the prime minister and i've
frequently referred to him as pinocchio
of course that gets to the nub of what
many conservative mps are worried about
he is of course being investigated by
the communist privileges committee about
whether he misled parliament over
particular that might usually be
considered a resigning offense let's see
and matt carry on i mean yeah he wants
to doesn't he i mean that is for sure
even if you know ministers resign or
cabinet ministers come and tell him to
go yeah that was his message after the
vote despite losing
148 of his mps he said we're carrying on
we've got important business to do in
terms of the cost of living crisis
northern ireland protocol et cetera and
that and housing announcement is due to
make later this week and i think that
the housing announcement will be key for
him because it's a thatcher policy